deux ministres à la caf de versailles ce
mercredi 30 septembre olivier véran
ministre des solidarités de la santé le
secrétaire d'état adrien taquet chargée
de l'enfance et des familles sont venues
présenter la première phase du service
public sur les pensions alimentaires
objectifs du dispositif éviter les
impayés prévenir la précarité des
familles d'abord elle est capable de
vous verser une allocation d'environ 116
euros par mois pour vous permettre déjà
de tenir en attendant que ce service
public est prélevée directement sur les
ressources du conjoint qui n'a pas
verser la pension alimentaire
ce qu'il vous doit de manière à vous le
verset y compris d'ailleurs en regardant
jusqu'à deux ans en arrière
ainsi il n'y aura plus demain de pension
alimentaire non versée
ce dispositif lancé ce 1er octobre est
attendue par des dizaines des familles
yvelinois c'est le cas pour jolie fille
serio lee mère de quatre enfants
originaire de montigny le bretonneux
séparés depuis quatre ans ça facilite
énormément de choses énormément démarche
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas
évident
malgré les procédures judiciaires malgré
est repassé devant la justice pour
fixez des pensions alimentaires dans les
yvelines on recense plus de trente neuf
mille familles monoparentales
actuellement 850 de procédure de
recouvrement pour impayés de pension
alimentaire sont ouvertes